the fate of a group of missionaries
kidnapped in haiti is still unclear this
morning the 16 americans and one
canadian including five children were
returning from an orphanage when they
were abducted the kidnappers are
demanding 17 million that's a million
dollars each for each hostage manuel
bajorkas is in port-au-prince with a
look at the conditions that led to this
kidnapping in the first place and the
danger that haitians face every single
day
the color and bustle of this central
marketplace in port-au-prince obscure a
stark reality
people here now live in a constant state
of fear
criminal gangs have swept in to field a
void left by an unstable government
mothers worry sending their kids off to
school
buses or vans full of passengers have
become easy prey for robbery or
kidnapping what is your fear
for his life he had to go out
to
a married father of one says if he
doesn't pay the gangs an extortion fee
they won't let him drive what happens if
you don't pay
that mean you cannot move can't operate
you would defend yourself
no way to operate
very difficult
these drivers are targets too
they're part of the small army that
delivers desperately needed food
medicine and other items from food for
the poor's central warehouse
things should be in transit monsignor
o'jay bouvois showed us it's nearly full
but that's the problem
it's heartbreaking because how the goods
available
but you can reach out to those people
have the goods available but you can't
reach out can't do that
kidnapping clergy and missionaries is
the gang's latest escalation may i ask
as a man of the cloth whether you're
feeling that insecurity as well
i do
i do feel that insecurity i live and
work here
and anybody can get kidnapped at any
time
the insecurity is even impacting the
international medical relief group
doctors without borders
which has had ambulances attacked and
healthcare workers
threatened recently they've had to
relocate some clinics from gang control
territory leaving those areas with
limited access to care the situation has
deteriorated that's for sure
but there is no way we are as boxers
without borders considering leaving the
country
food for the poor also says it doesn't
plan to leave and with looking for ways
to work around some of those really
dangerous areas these organizations of
course are praying for the safe release
of the missionaries but hoping the
spotlight on them sheds light on what
people here face every day gail
well we're all watching thank you very
much manuel buharkus reporting from
haiti